it's been almost a whole year but we  finally heard about rise of the Tomb  Raider coming to PlayStation 4 i'm tony  and this gamespot news update should  make sony fans very happy this fall will  see the release of rise of the tomb  Raider's 20 years celebration edition on  ps4 this includes all the previous DLC  outfits and weapon skins plus an artbook  co-op endurance mode and a brand new  story chapter called blood ties even  better you'll be able to play this  chapter in PlayStation VR season pass  holders on xbox one and pc will get this  new content for free but it's all  included in the ps4 version rise of the  Tomb Raider 20 years celebration edition  launches on october eleventh we gave the  original release a 9 out of 10 so  consider that a strong endorsement for  this new version of the game especially  if you're a ps4 owner and if you want to  keep up with all of our crops latest  adventures you're already in the right  place  you